[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and i can tell you my
love for you will still be strong after
the boys season 3 trailer has gone
really really bad intro and with the new
teaser now hitting the internet i
thought we'd break down all the easter
eggs hidden details and things you
missed in the boys season 3 trailer
there will be some spoilers here in
regards to the comics so if you don't
want anything ruined then i'll recommend
that you turn off now make sure you hit
the thumbs up button if you enjoy the
video and don't forget to subscribe as
we're going to be doing a lot of boys
coverage over the next coming months
without the way you guys are the real
heroes now let's get into our boys
season 3 breakdown
[Music]
give me give me give me some time to
think i'm in the bathroom looking at me
facing the mirror is all i need
wait until the reaper takes my life
now the biggest takeaway from this
teaser is that the boys will be taking
compound v themselves and this also
pulls directly from the comics in order
to level the playing field they injected
themselves with the substance and they
demonstrate their powers at several
points the trailer opens with butcher
immediately after he's just taken it and
throughout we watch as he tries to keep
this under wraps you very much get the
feeling of rage within him and he shoots
lasers out of his eyes which is
something that homelander also does all
the time as well
during one moment we see him fighting
his supes and he kicks the crap out of
him which shows just how much it's
improved his strength he vomits at one
point as well and i'm guessing that this
is the side effect of taking the drug
the song you hear in the background is
bones by imagine dragons and this is
very much discussing a new magic within
someone which is of course represented
by butch's transformation the teaser
very much begins as a character piece in
which we see several of the people in
quick shots throughout but you're
looking in the mirror is reflected by
homelander who we see doing the same
thing right as the former is in a
rundown bathroom the ladder is in a
luxury apartment surrounded by artwork
it's difficult to make out what all of
this is but it's heavily based around
old wars which sort of foreshadows the
battles that will be happening in the
show now just in the same way that
butcher now has powers that reflect
homelanders we get them both followed by
black noir in the comics it's real that
he and homelander are a lot closer than
you think and though i don't want to
spoil one of the big potential twists
it's important to bear these three
people in mind as they're in somewhat of
a triangle in which the three are very
much tied in with one another next we
cut to huey and whereas the last three
people were in positions of power he
seems very vulnerable i'm guessing that
he's hiding out after finding out about
victoria who he ended up working for at
the end of season 2. victoria was
revealed to be a vort plant within the
government last time and they'd
obviously want to cover this up big is
based on the character vic the veep who
in the comics was also a vault plant as
well unlike the show though victor
didn't have any powers and this might
help with something that we'll talk
about in just a bit avoid eventually
manipulate events so that he became the
president of the united states and thus
they had someone in the white house who
could basically green eye all of their
operations however his presidency didn't
last that long as he was eventually
killed by homelander in his superhero
uprising in the comics he eventually
built up to this through homeland as
slowly being driven insane by blackmail
material sent to him by black noir
however with victoria being a supes
herself it's going to be interesting to
see how they play it she's definitely
someone that could stand up to
homelander and even when he arrived at
the crowd during season 2 you could see
her staring at him ready to pop his head
off i think kiwi will of course discover
that she's actually evolved plant and
then he'll reunite with the boys now
later on in the teaser he gets his arm
broken by kimiko her doing this could be
because he's just had a bit of v himself
and he will of course need it if the
soups discover he knows the truth about
vic
[Music]
whereas the first handful of shots were
focused on heads we next get a focus on
hands namely the clenching of them the
trailer shows a scene that was dropped
online last month in which starlight and
homelander talk to the press she
clenches her fist behind her back
because she knows she's lying about what
really happened in season two
starlight is well aware of the plane
crash and its cover-up but she's keeping
the peace so that the soup's war doesn't
end up destroying the planet her hand
clenching is followed by mother's milk
and we get some more mirroring shots
with stan edgar taking his glasses off
which is then followed by frenchie lots
of amazing couplings in this between the
two sides and it really works well for
the teaser i think
now we know that the first episode will
be called payback which is the name of a
superhero team in the comics originally
they were led by stormfront and the term
payback could also be used to signify
them getting revenge on the boys for
what they did to her in the seven
another key member of the group was
soldier boy who will be played by jensen
ackles in the next season he's basically
a captain america parody that's a super
patriot only interested in proving that
america is the best in the comics there
were several people that took up the
mantle and one that even ended up
sleeping with homelander it'll be
interesting to see if they go this route
i think most likely that we'll get him
facing off against homelander as they
both by the control now at one point we
get a wall of superhero misdeeds on
newspapers this does include soulja boy
who is referred to as a fallen soldier
judging by the end of the trailer it
looks like they're doing a similar story
to captain america where they pretended
that he died and then revived him he
very much seems like he's been kept in
stasis or something and much like
stormfront he's an extremely ill
character who retained their you through
compound b we see him fighting in the
trailer and you the vignette over the
top of the footage and makes it seem
older so i'm guessing this is one of the
last missions he had before he was put
in stasis guy seems off the leash and
just going wild so they probably had to
put a stop to him now they likely need
him back after stormfront was revealed
to be a nazi and it makes sense of what
would bring out a world war ii hero to
show they don't have any affiliations to
any of that group another article
chronicles the death of huey's
girlfriend in the first season which
pretty much kickstarted the events that
led to everything there's also mention
of the tech knight who is rumored to be
appearing in this season he's basically
batman with a bit of a weird fetish and
he has one of the funniest deaths in the
entire run i don't want to spoil it but
there's a lot of gun cocking and i love
how the boys are clearly arming up while
some other milk wears a t-shirt that
says stop the violence this idea of
stopping the violence is very much
mirrored in the next shot which seems to
be a protest between people wanting
peace and the police a train busts up in
the middle and opens up a can of turbo
rush which seems to quieten things down
now if you don't know and i'm absolutely
dying here this is riffing on the
kendall jenner pepsi ad in which she did
something similar there was a big
protest everyone kicking off but she
arrived with some pepsi and saved the
day if only he could funny could sort
out all the world's problems kendall we
just would love to have a pepsi with you
now this commercialization is mirrored
in the pop band that then appears and we
see them at two locations making me
think that they do this throughout the
season the star on the main one's chest
is very similar to captain america's so
it could be roughing on the star
spangled man with a plan and basically
doing that for soldier boy ashley and
the writer get it on with some of her
hair falling out which is coupled by a
shot later on in which she rips it out
her hair fell out in the second season
after the stress caused by homeland i
got too much and i'm guessing he rips it
off which will make her panic a bit huge
kisses starlight in public and
homelander pushes a train's stomach
before threatening him similar how he
did to starlight in season two at this
point we see a body exploding and it is
difficult to make out who exactly is
doing this they have long hair and a red
coat but it doesn't look like victoria
instead i think it might actually be
cindy who you might recall had similar
powers to victoria in season 2. we never
got a resolution to her story and it
makes sense that she'd still be out
there somewhere we later see her
exploding someone's jaw and what i
believe is a moment that precedes this
one later on starlight sees a man
exploding and though it might be linked
to her if you slow down the footage you
can actually see a man jumping out of
him guy probably done an ant-man and
jumped up someone's butt and then went
back to normal size which yeah not a
nice way to go now there's a sign that
says lucky which he isn't and that's not
even a joke wish i could show all these
exploding scenes but youtube is really
funny about them things and i'm probably
gonna get butchered for playing four
seconds of imagine dragons so hashtag
praise steven spoilsberg still gets to
monetize the video
[Music]
now i think homelander has a homeland a
dildo at one point which we'll not get
into and we also meet a brand new
character in the crimson countess she's
very much a school at which parody who
of course has had a lot of popularity
recently with the show one division
whereas the scarlet witch's powers have
sort of transcended into reality warping
the count test is more of a first level
abilities such as firing things from her
hands this is usually fire though in the
teaser it does look like red chaos
energy machine was very much used as a
tool of propaganda against the russians
much in the same way that soulja boy was
used in world war ii i don't think
they'll go to the level where she's able
to change the world around her but
there's still a lot of things they can
do with the character and she might even
bring her vibrator to life or something
along those lines now she's being played
by laurie holden who was andrea in the
walking dead and i can't wait to see
what she brings to the show he destroys
the statue of homelander which spills
open with guts which yet no idea what's
going on there and maybe there was
someone inside from here we catch the
deep and he appears to be looking at an
orgy later on he has sex with someone
but he's looking at an octopus whilst
doing it which yeah
this trailer what the hell are they
doing
now we also know that the season will
have the events of herogasm playing out
in the show this was the limited six
issue series in the comics that was
basically a sordid sex party for the
soups annually they'd throw the event
that allowed the characters to let their
hair down and have whatever their heart
desired what would create a cover story
for the group and say that they'd gone
off world to fight some intergalactic
threats but they were just really
sucking on them titties the boys ended
up infiltrating this and black nour
actually stuck his thumb up huey's butt
at one point and he said good soldier
this was a reference to the dark knight
returns and had to read it several times
to be like did he actually do that
because it's pretty messed up in the
comics now from here we go to homelander
landing at a rally this is banners
saying keep america safe and also guard
guns in homeland in the crowd we can see
someone wearing horns and this is
clearly playing on january 6th getting
very very political and clearly it's a
comment on the climate in the us right
now which the boys has never really
shied away from homeland his son seems
very angry at one point and i'm glad
he's returning and we even get old
homelander milking a cow which is a nod
to how much i'm gonna be milking this
show when it comes out now an
interesting part comes when we see
french in chemical dancing in what seems
to be a musical i'm guessing this is a
fantasy but it fits the music video
aesthetic that this teaser is going for
lastly we end on the resurrection of
soulja boy and throughout the teaser we
also get shots of his mask he's gonna
cause a lot of problems and if he was
put on ice literally then that's
probably been for a good reason guys
being frozen for far too long and no
doubt he's gonna thaw out and be very
thought about it very good puns as
always and that wraps up the trailer
[Music]
now as for my thoughts on the trailer
i'm really really excited for it and i
love the two seasons as well as the
animated spin-off there's something just
really funny about the boys and not only
does it do comic book parodies really
well it also discusses things like
commercialism politics and the way the
world is i think homelander is going to
go off the edge in it and it's going to
be interesting to see a hero unleash
doing whatever they want with their
abilities we're shaping up to a great
season especially with all the comics
that are going to be referenced in it
and i can't wait until it releases on
the 3rd of june obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on it so make sure
you comment below and let me know also
if you've enjoyed the video please hit
the thumbs up button and make sure you
subscribe for breakdowns like this every
day if you want something else to watch
we have our boys diabolical breakdown on
screen right now which goes through
things like the comic spin-off
homelanders origin story and a lot more
definitely go check it out right after
this and without the way hope you
enjoyed the rest of your weekend take
care peace